um okay fine whatever um what up guys
welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel oh god today i am going
to be reacting to some
you know like red pill content live
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it i'm asking for donations
poor favor
please
please dear god i just spent like
oh my god more money than i have
on [ __ ] to make this
live podcast which is going to be friday
at 8 00 gmt which is like 2 central time
3 eastern
time don't know what it is california
time but you guys get the gist okay send
donations por favor please and thank you
i'm sorry if you were here earlier and
my live stream just cut off my power
went out
the apps here are kind of weird they
like don't tell you
when you're like low on power so i just
hopped off my me they just like shut
your power off i'm like
all right thank you guys thank you
british power
um anyways so
i
will be
i will be going
and reacting to a brittany lee video
that i was just watching before
i'm making myself
okay let me see
did i see your request no i'm sorry my
power went out i i got a bit turned back
on so it's fine but
oh my gosh i was that was that was rough
that was rough
to fit in this relationship my girl from
like if you
at betterhelp.com forward
we are speaking about in this video is
the excellent woman that we spoke about
in last week's video and i feel like
excellent women we have the hardest time
finding someone to love and be loved by
and it's not because there is something
wrong with us like these podcasts want
us to believe however it is that we are
so expensive that the average joe is
just not enough and i'm going to be
using okay but this is this is the
question
do the guys you want want you
and if they don't want you
then what do you have to do to make them
want you
i don't understand why
as women like we don't ever take
responsibility for anything everything
is everyone else
the reason nobody swooped you up is
because you're too expensive ma'am man
okay i i have friends that are the
picture
perfect image of what a wife is right
like they are
born raised made to be a wife like much
more wifey than me
okay like i don't
i think i'll be okay i'm not too worried
about it
but i have friends that like
from the time they were 12 years old
or 13 whatever boys and girls started
dating they've had guys lined up to date
them there's this girl in my college
name was ani
that girl could not stay single because
she was so wifey and like all of the
guys like that everyone wanted always
wanted her because she's
she's like pretty smart every everything
you would want in a girl right like not
eh
anyways anyways my point is
the men that everyone wanted were lined
up to date her
because she had better qualities of a
wife than i did
look
guys we can't all get first place
we can't it's okay but
instead of thinking okay what is ani
doing right what can i do to be more
like any girls like this will be like
it's them ladies
your price is too high like this that's
so stupid oh my gosh okay
can you guys hear me okay
let me know
some language in this video too small
expensive not enough my audience you are
women who are high value women you are
women of substance but lady how do you
know that you don't know who's watching
your video ma'am
quality of value so i know it definitely
won't offend you but i know that there's
going to be men that are too small to
even comprehend what i'm saying and like
okay i'm not too small to comprehend
what you're saying i literally
understand it perfectly i just think
you're wrong
that's why like why is women
well they just don't comprehend what i'm
saying no they just think you're wrong
that's like when men okay the equivalent
of that is men saying
everyone hates me because i'm they're
jealous of me no man they just don't
like you for whatever reason
like not everything is jealousy or they
don't understand like they just think
you're wrong
you can't be right all the time like box
that you guys do not argue with them in
the comments that you just take away
what you need to take away from today's
video and like i said we are not your
average woman we are women that know who
we are have been through enough trials
and tribulations come out on the other
end bigger and better
so you basically just said we're
traumatized do you mean
let me know in the chat do you guys
enjoy traumatized women
damaged women women that have been
through a lot is that
is that the ideal
look
if you can go through trauma and still
be tough and not like this is what i say
i've been
i've been in like a toxic relationship
before but i'm not gonna put that on the
next guy i'm not gonna like come out
damaged and bitter from it
no
i refuse i refuse okay
i refuse to ever let a bad experience
let me look at the world bitter i will
not i will i will not let somebody take
that away from me i will always be happy
and that's that's what happens though to
women over time the more relationships
they go in and out of the more they
start to believe men are trash the more
they start to just become bitter towards
the world
and i will never give someone that power
over me to take over my happy-go-lucky
spirit oh no oh no
we are women who are healed or still
healing we are women that are aware of
our value we know our calling in life we
know where we're going in line okay what
dictates if something is valuable
the demand
[Music]
if i okay if i put out my used beat down
air forces and i tried to sell them for
a thousand dollars
does that make them worth a thousand
dollars now ladies i'm not telling you
to go out there and
and you know just have low self-esteem
because i think like sometimes when us
women like watch a lot of the red pill
content like it kind of makes us like
like they're always talking not talking
down on women but just like
talking about every like bad part about
women
like all the time right like oh she's
over 25
don't date her i've seen tweets like
that i'm like damn 25
anyways my point my point is this
it's not it's not to say like have no
self-esteem
what i'm saying is like is what you're
asking for realistic are you getting
offers from the men that you want and if
you're not why is that
and you can't just blame everyone else
like what in you do you need to change
and i'm not above it look at everyone
everyone's got to improve
we have goals we have dreams we have
vision we have ambition we are women
that just have that feeling inside that
we are called for something bigger and
better we don't know what it is we just
know that inside there's something great
for us to do and whether you are famous
or not people know your name or not you
know exactly who you are and you are
extremely expensive and the average guy
sorry not sorry just does not measure up
let's be honest you're a woman who has
tried to humble herself now let's now
i'm gonna i'm gonna flip the coin okay
i do think there is a shortage of
husbands and a lot of men out there
without purpose
i i do think that dating is harder today
because of like social media
video games like a lot of stuff that
like
i don't know like i do think there's a
shortage of husbands but there's also a
shortage of wives like i think the
problems on both sides
but
do the men do the men you want want you
that's that's the real question self and
get with the guy that is quote unquote
average get with a guy that is not quite
on your level and when i'm speaking
about level i'm not just talking about
financially however that too is very
important i'm not going to dismiss that
i'm talking about on your level of
ambition on your level mentally
emotionally spiritually they are nice
guys and on paypal you wouldn't be able
to necessarily fault them however you
with them you in that relationship with
them constantly feel a sense of i'm
settling i'm making myself smaller okay
bernie who are you talking to i'm gonna
crack my neck i'm sorry
okay i'm done um who are you talking to
the average woman makes like 35 000 a
year
the average man makes 45 000 like from a
macro level
how are you more ambitious
i don't i don't get it in this
relationship i'm having to dumb myself
down a bit to be with this person i'm
having to act like i don't want xyz to
be with this person but i do want x y z
but the reality and the truth is that
why does my screen keep getting darker
let me see
does it
it looks the same on here
not everybody is meant for you not
everybody has the capacity for you and i
love that word so much because when i
heard it when i first heard it years ago
it just not everybody has the capacity
for you is that just another way of
saying not everybody likes you duh
like
how does this girl have this many
subscribers i do not get it
but if you live in london you can come
on my channel we could talk about this
in person
so much sense like there are guys out
there that just cannot and we use the
word handle but it's not that we want to
be handled is that we want to be covered
we want to be protected we want to be
embraced all of who we are and all of
who we will be and it's like with men
that don't have the capacity for you you
can't be all of who you are because
these men just don't understand they
just can't understand you they can't
read you they can't on a spiritual level
understand but it's like she's saying a
whole lot of nothing like absolutely
nothing
also guys consider sending a donation
for um
youtube equipment again
i'm trying to raise money for four more
microphones
i have
four right now and a sound board i'm at
like
250 ish maybe 245 in terms of like how
much super chats i have so i'm trying to
get to a thousand
anyways
youtube isn't allowing you to send super
chats
why
and this comments funny men can't handle
me like congrats you're difficult to
live with and you think it's a flex
oh my gosh
the gravity and as sarah jakes would say
the weight of who you are and that maybe
just be speaking to a small percentage
of women but i know exactly who this
video is for and i'm speaking directly
to you and i want you to know that i
understand typically these men look it
and i understand being like again i
understand being driven
and wanting a guy like i am very driven
i've always been complimented on my work
ethic that is one thing since i was like
yay years old that i have always always
always been complimented on
like
i've always gotten recommendations from
every job i've worked every coach i've
ever had now look i don't work smart
that's my problem i work hard not smart
everyone everyone's got a flaw that's
mine but
i get what she's saying
but but brittany
if the guys you want don't want you like
the answer isn't oh well i'm better than
all these guys anyway like what the
see who you are wait did i wear this top
of my last video
cats are disabled in certain countries
that's so weird i just got it
um
like
that's so odd
it's just weird
is it still not working guys
i lost video no i didn't it was a light
one oh it was a different one sorry
sorry
yeah when a man doesn't understand or
comprehend fully who you are doesn't
know how to manage don't know how to
handle you they will typically try you
notice this it's them damn them them
never me never me trying to find a way
to control you and the reason why they
try to control you or confine you is
because it makes them feel uncomfortable
and my last relationship when i was
writing down some of the red flags
whilst i was still in the relationship
and i will read exactly what i wrote
down in my red flags no i said i fear
that if i grow past where i am would he
be able to handle it okay i need what
does that mean
that is very telling and it's like if i
make you feel uncomfortable now and i
haven't reached my full potential i
haven't even peaked yet what are you
going to do what are you talking about
like making more money
getting in better shape like what
when i am a
millionaire traveling the world speaking
to tens and hundreds of thousands of
people when more people know my name
when i become
you tried to super chat me three times
super chat's working fine thank you for
the five dollar donation
karissa it might be the country you're
in
because sometimes i try to super chat
people and it like i have to go on a
computer to do it because i have to
change like the currency sadly
youtube confuses me but thank you so
much for the super chat
like all she's saying in a bunch of
different ways is it's not me it's him
it's not me it's him
like
like what
i'm just trying to think of the possible
examples of what this could mean she
i've seen her videos over time she's
gained weight and i'm saying this like
respectfully most people gain weight
over time in general right most people
are not in better shape over time
so it's obviously not
the weight like in the most respectful
way possible
i've seen your videos since you were
like 25 you've gained weight second
thing it could be his career so if i
make more money than him is it going to
make him uncomfortable
most guys don't care
guys let me know in the chat do you care
if your girl makes more money than you
does it bother you most guys it's just
like oh that's cool
and they just don't care my brothers
have actually always said they don't
want a girl that like doesn't
have a career weirdly enough like that's
really
in my family that's something like my
mom has always told my brothers to go
after female engineers or like hi like
smart girls
um but in general like it's different
though like men might appreciate that
like on like a personal level but men
aren't attracted to that like they don't
want to
have sex
with our work ethic and ambition
okay me like women want to bang guys
with that like men it's more like oh
that's like a good trait and they like
you as a person i don't know that that's
what i've seen okay my best self what
are you going to do if you can't handle
me where i am or when i tell you about
my small winds or my winds you're not
even enthusiastic about it or you find a
way to try and sun me trying to find a
way to downplay me what are you gonna do
i want you guys to know that i know
exactly what i'm talking about okay
because i've experienced this firsthand
not just with him but with others as
well there were literally times when i
didn't want people to compliment me in
front of him because i didn't want him
to feel comfortable because i know that
when people have complimented me in
front of him or told him about me he's
almost shrugged it off and been like
like i remember when he was in antigua
one of the ladies i don't know i don't
understand
he was like your wife is so beautiful
and i was like gosh don't say that don't
say in front of him but i kind of smiled
and was like thank you i don't even
think he even acknowledged it two
minutes we just continued on walking and
like i know the type of man that i want
to be with like if someone says your
wife is beautiful i want him to have the
biggest smile on his face i want him to
grab me and hold me and make a little
cute joke or something i never felt like
i could be me all of me with him and
that is so sad i i don't think
i had to say this i don't think you can
be all of yourself with anyone
this is just personal opinion we all
like okay
i have girls that i'm friends with that
i have nothing in common with
like at all but you can be friends with
people and just not talk about like the
things that you guys don't agree on or
don't have in common
like a lot of people ask me do you red
pill your friends i'm like i will if
they want to be and i'll don't get me
wrong i talk to them a little bit but
like
most girls don't like talk about this
stuff all day why would i force my
interest on them
like there's sides of my mom that my dad
doesn't see all the time because
like it's just they're into different
stuff i don't know
but i don't what she's talking about to
me shouldn't even be that big of a deal
i remember he came to one of my shows
and after the event someone came up to
us and was like to him oh you're so
lucky and i automatically felt the urge
not because i necessarily meant it i
automatically felt the urge to say no
i'm the lucky one to kind of defuse it
like i didn't want him to go home
thinking what does she mean i'm lucky
this is techie mate it's techie it's
like a lot of time was spent making sure
that he felt man enough at the end it
just wasn't enough and he would even say
to me at times i can't give you what
you're asking for i feel like i'm not
enough and i would say you are enough
honestly he wasn't enough and it sounds
bad for honesty
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
um
he is the best policy don't try and make
him enough he even isn't okay this this
isn't a bad advice actually
women go into relationships trying to
change man
and we don't we don't accept them for
who they are now we just more of like
want them a lot of times to be something
they're not so what i think she's saying
now is don't try to change a guy to like
be something he's not like he is who he
is i agree with that i agree with that
but
you have to take some like she takes no
accountability in any of this she just
says
he wasn't enough well
he always said he didn't feel man enough
well why did he feel like that
did you contribute to him feeling like
that ever
oh let me know
it isn't the bare minimum stuff i was
asking him to do he could not do it
because it wasn't in him to do right i'm
going to talk about settling a little
bit later but what i did want to show
you guys is the visual analogy that god
showed me about my future husband and
the different types of guys that i've
dated in the past okay the bible talks
about our husbands being our spiritual
covering the bible says the head of
every man is christ and the head of
every woman is her husband your husband
will be your spiritual covering your
physical covering your protector okay i
used to
when i was super because i was really
involved in the church before i moved
out of milwaukee like i was going to
bible study like twice a week okay
and at that point when i was dating i
really wanted a guy that was like super
into god right and i was like he has to
because you know i want to get closer to
god and
but the problem with that here's the
problem with that men aren't really in
the church like it was like three girls
to one guy so i'm like if i want to date
in my church how will i do that if
there's three girls to one guy
the other issue okay issue
number two
is i was thinking like my mom wouldn't
have married my dad because my dad isn't
that religious but my dad is like the
definition of a great man like he he is
a great guy he doesn't cheat he doesn't
drink he doesn't smoke he doesn't have
social media like my dad is like
what i i would aspire to like look for
in a husband
and i'm like i would have eliminated my
dad i'm like um so i don't know it's
kind of like
i think like
a guy that's a christian and like trying
to get closer towards god is like a
bonus but i think character is more
important than religion in my opinion
um
it's odd that women start off thinking i
can mold him into what i want instead of
finding someone who's
already what they want settling
setting themselves up for wasting time
i'm going to tell you and this is guys
in the manosphere don't really want to
admit this
there is a shortage of husbands there's
absolutely a shortage of wives i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you that
but there are a lot of men
that
are are very much like
mentally like kids to be honest
um
so
i think a lot of girls like
fall in love
with those guys like i'm like a personal
like level like being friends with them
or whatever but then like when it comes
to becoming like more practical and like
having to rely on them they realize it's
like you can't
um
so that that is
my opinion on that
but no that's as women we always want to
fix things we'll provide uh our girls
miss all the good guys but
guys it's partially yes girls do miss
all the good guys but
in my opinion i think there is a
shortage of husbands too and men that
just want to play videos all game get
games all day have porn addictions like
these are all
problems these are all problems
and
we want to talk about women all day and
i'm going to give you guys that
a lot of issues
but it goes on both sides
um yeah but men propose so the shortage
of wives may um
matter more than the amount of husbands
i don't get it
because if there's a shortage of
husbands
like
i think it would be the same issue
because then you have a bunch of men
proposing to women that don't want them
so it's like the same
issue both ways
um pearl the shortage is primarily
women's fault
right guys sure i am with you i am with
you but like you have to realize we're
individuals so like i'm a woman what did
i do to create a shortage of husbands
like i'm what what did i do i didn't
sign up for feminism i like i didn't do
any of that
like i you can't
you can't like
like
blame all of us like like a lot of those
the reason people are the way they are
they are today was wasn't our generation
it was what we were taught from the
previous generation now luckily like my
mom never really subscribed to any of
that but like
it's tough it surrounds you in the media
it surrounds you in our culture it
surrounds you in college like even when
i was in college like i probably would
have identified as a feminist for one or
two years until i just realized it was
stupid but
like
at an individual level at like a society
level yes women are responsible for that
i i'm with you
but what what did i do like i didn't do
anything
um
like i didn't i didn't invent porn like
what
i didn't you know
um okay so yes okay the other thing and
women should date older our culture
doesn't promote age gap dating i
actually agree with you i never thought
about
i was very anti-age gap
um and um there's like drawbacks with
age gap i really
i don't think 20 years
is great but i think like 15 or less is
cool because the only reason is because
like men don't live as long as women so
when i get married i'm trying to like
marry someone i can hang out with for a
long time like that
like like i'm trying to i'm trying to
hang out
and not spend the last 20 years of my
life alone like i don't want to do that
but especially but again i'm in a very
different position than most women
because i have access to resources like
from my dad like that that's very
different than most women i i
acknowledge that
but
but but but but
i'm with you i'm with you there internet
porn is wrecking a lot of guys um who
would have otherwise leveled up
themselves and the type of men women
would want to marry yeah that's very
true
that's very true
um
it took me roughly 10 years to realize
that yeah and i've talked to a lot of
guys that are addicted to porn
like it
it's kind of sad because if i date
someone i've been asked like if i'd
expect my husband to watch porn and i
kind of just like well he probably is
going to i can't really stop it
because like most men watch porn
you know like what am i supposed to do
um
i don't really see how women are
responsible for anyone but themselves
well they're talking about like a lot of
the issues we have today are the result
of feminism right like the feminine men
a lot of times stem from feminism right
like they would demand they would say
masculinity is bad all this stuff at a
society level sure but what again what
what did i do
i was just born um
what introduced what topic friday
girls cannot think other than their own
that's the problem they just pair what
they've been taught and act like they're
super smart okay
that's true for a lot of girls
but i like to think i'm different
um age gap means nothing if the guy has
the right mentality i agree there are
some fine
i don't know when it happened okay
because i never found old guys
attractive ever but when i hit like 23
or 24 i'm like
are dads hot now are these 40 year old
men like i never even looked at them
when i was 20 19 20 21 22 never even
like
gave them the time of day i remember
when i was 21 i was going on dates with
like a 30 year old and i thought it was
so weird i couldn't get past it
but it was weird when i hit like 23 24
i was like oh my god these men are hot
weird weird experience
um
let's see girls um
generation size age gaps have awful
divorce rates yes that's true
we want to push age gaps but the stats
don't
favor you to be honest um
[Music]
better 20 years with a guy you want to
who you want who dies of old age than
this subtle a guy your age that you're
miserable with why are those the only
two options
those aren't the only two options
pearl there's a difference between you
when you're reacting
and you around your friends it's two
different people you red pill when
reading but the opposite of the pre-game
oh that's because um the pre-game like
that was just a test
as i've said before guys
you can't red pill everybody so if i'm
just testing my mics i'm not gonna have
a full-on debate with you
okay because that's not what you're
signing up for
okay
i'm i'm
more than willing to have those
conversations but i'm not gonna like
do that to people that i like play
volleyball with unless they're signing
up for it so when i actually have the
show
sure
sure i have a lot of conversations with
these girls off camera but i'm not gonna
yeah
i don't i really i don't actually need
to explain that
but there's a difference you have to
like
i don't know kind of balance it
um
because when i'm gonna have
conversations with the people that go on
before and just be like look
this is how it's gonna be i'm not
responsible if anybody gets clipped or
anything okay
your friend called men's pedos oh my god
and i told her on the show i was like
what are you talking about gaby
oh my gosh
like
and like also when she was going off i
was fixing the mic so i was kind of like
half in half out trying to fix it um
like i was i was trying to figure out a
million things and there's drunk girls
there's cords everywhere guys
there's a lot that goes into this stuff
if you want if you want to come in here
and do it for me go ahead
but
oh my goodness no i i said on there
that
that that is weird no
um
okay looking
i am only
six months older than my wife
would you do an episode about domestic
discipline relationships
um i don't know
tact is important you want to make an
enemy without a point without making an
enemy no that's true and that's what i'm
saying like
i'm trying
to like it's very tough because you have
to understand like when you work with
people when you go to work right and
volleyball for me like is kind of like a
job
everyone has opinions about [ __ ] but you
don't know you don't talk about them all
the time
right you don't go to work and ask
everyone their opinion is on inter
intersexual like dynamics and all this
stuff
and i've like actually been very clear
that i'm very much pro-man like they all
know this on my team but it's not like
all we talk about
so
am i gonna roast girls coming on my show
to help me test my mics
no but when i actually do a show yeah
well we'll it'll get heated
don't worry
but guys i'm trying to test my
microphones get my [ __ ] off the ground
anyways sorry it just annoyed me i got
all these comments that were like why
didn't you say anything i'm like y'all
i'm trying to fix my microphones this
isn't a real show
not yet anyway sorry
have the bigger responsibility when it
comes to us which means that your
husband has to be greater than you in
many different aspects and this is why
it's so important to know who you are
because when you know who you are you
know what type of man you need when you
know where you're going you know what
type of man you would need to go with
you there and it's crazy because i have
male friends who even when i was in a
relationship saw me more than my ex saw
me and they would speak into my future
they were speaking to where i'm going
and one of my good friends michael which
i speak about so much on his channel
always why don't you date him
datum
date him
uh thank you so much for the five dollar
super chat thank you so much
oh my god thank you
thank you thank you thank you i
appreciate it so much guys we're almost
to three hundred dollars out of the
thousand dollars and i'm trying to raise
four
mics okay also you can send me donations
at justpearlythingsoncashapp
or um hannapearldavis at 2hs hannah nah
pearldavis gmail.com at paypal
for paypal okay you told me briny you're
going xyz this is the type of man that
you need you need a man that's going to
be secure i mean very secure so that
when there's women around that are
trying to get at him that he only has
eyes for you like this is what my male
friends just say to me like and
encourage me so much and it's so true
your husband has to be great he has to
have big arms big hands to handle you as
the wife there's so many unequally yoked
relationships where the wife is a giant
spiritually mentally physically
physically
but you know what i mean and the husband
is just there and i'm not saying that
because there's some men like you look
at joyce meyer and her husband i'm not
saying that she's greater than him
because we don't know what happens
behind closed doors however god's given
joyce meyer the bigger vision and he's
there to support as long as the man that
you're with or the man that you are
wanting to be with will support he's
describing betas
which is fine honestly i don't
i have a bigger personality right i'm a
chit chatter i get along best with guys
that also have big personalities or just
let me let me go off
lily don't talk at all those are my two
types they like don't talk
or
yeah
support you encourage you cover you even
if he doesn't have what you have even if
he doesn't have the same calling as you
he cannot be in sir cure that's the main
point when you know who you are you're
going to know what type of man is going
to compliment you or
stifle you i'm going to get into this
analogy that god gave me after i went
for my breakup last year so let's not
waste any time um
this is what i'm saying what's easy to
forget about youtube is that for people
like pearl it's not just entertainment
it's business and with business you have
to
handle things delicately
with business
no well yeah partially partially but
it's also like personal relationships i
believe you can be friends with people
that don't agree with you on everything
and have very different views in the
world i know that's really not like the
opinion in the manosphere like all your
friends have to be the same
but like
i don't know if someone's supportive
nice to me and like i enjoy hanging out
with them i don't understand why i have
to agree with them on everything
like and so if she wants to sign up to
be in a debate
we can do that but like i don't know
just just my opinion but i'm just not
big enough for you and this is what you
look like trying to be covered by them
there are other men out there who talk a
good game they could fool you and your
mama they act like they're so secure in
themselves they got that they know who
they are they even may look manly they
may even look like they can handle and
cover you and people from the outside
may be like this is a great match he
looks like he's just strong enough for
her but you know in the relationship the
insecurities that the person has they
take out on you the many ways he tries
to tear you down to downplay you and the
truth is he to downplay you i don't
bring can you give me one specific
example one
that isn't
he wasn't getting excited when someone
complimented me like that was basically
what you said earlier i need one
specific example
cannot fully because she ever told you
about what happened with her husband no
i've never heard that cover you because
he's not big enough for you like you can
see i am not fully covered just about a
lot of women settle hair he's just about
big enough for me they will set her hair
and be like
yeah this is
what is the other option like what
do you want to wait forever and just
never get married that's the path you're
on like i'm being serious like you
you're an attractive woman right you're
not you're not bad looking
um
you know you got stuff going for you but
if you're not getting the results that
you want like
the answer isn't everyone else
is the problem that's why like all these
good women are still single like like
there's a deficiency
it's okay a lot we all have deficiencies
but like what is yours
but everything you keep on bringing up
is
them i don't know but if you are to grow
and get bigger and bigger that covering
gets smaller and smaller and smaller for
you now
this is the man that god has for you and
the man god has for me so listen up
future wives he is able to cover you and
then some and the then some is your
flaws your quirks the annoying parts
about you your grumpiness your monthly
mood swings your occasional wrong ways
of thinking basically your imperfections
which we all have all the things that
make us human that's the densum that's
the overflow of his covering not only
that what he also is able to cover is
your ambition what you've managed to
achieve and what you still have
potential to achieve he can cover the
money that you're making now and the
money that you are about to make he can
cover the children that you don't have
i'm so confused you mean like
financially
you want this guy to pay for everything
you're 30 like
oh my gosh this is what
let let me know if you find him let me
let me just i'll shut up yes and even if
you do have children he's able to cover
those children too this man's arms are
so wide his vision is so wide that it's
more than enough to cover every part of
you and if this doesn't get you excited
about your potential husband i don't
know what will this is the man you
should be looking for so for those of
you who have you dated one
what are your results
look
oh my gosh out there dating collect your
data collect the data that you need and
see if this man will be able to cover
you
wholly test him talk about what you've
achieved talk about what you want to
achieve see his posture does he get a
bit fiddly or does he stare you in the
eye does his eyes light up when you're
telling him about your goals and your
dreams oh my god most men don't want to
listen to us talk
it's a sad reality
most men just want you to shut the f up
i'm going to be honest
this isn't a fun reality look at i'm a
chit chatter right i love i love me a
good discussion
i love me a good chit chat
but yeah most men just want to be like
left alone
they want you to be there but like in
the other room
does he get a smile on his face does he
become happy does he become in awe
although he would kind of be like i
don't know why these women are always
telling me about their accomplishments
man don't really care like that still
like does he get intimidated how does he
react watch his reaction tell him the
right things ask the right questions
ladies this will tell you everything
what's the reaction tense the energy
okay because a lot of things that guys
do are non-verbal watch his eyes is he
looking around is he paying attention to
what you're saying does he feel
uncomfortable you'll see it you ladies
you ladies do not need a man that is so
small that you make him feel insecure
you're not trying to make him feel
insecure his insecurities are making him
feel inferior and insecure you do not
need a man
i okay i agree with that
your insecurities are not your partner's
problem the same way like both ways
both ways it is not your pr partner's
problem
but but i'm going to do b doubles
advocate here but
[Music]
are you nagging on him a little bit is
that making him feel insecure look at
i've been there
i've been there
i can be a nagger sometime i'm not gonna
lie to you i can be a little bit of a
nagger okay
let's let's look within let's look
within is going to compete with you you
need a man that's going to complete with
you i am not marrying any man who is in
competition with me because i'm not in
competition with you babe what's mine is
yours what's yours is mine let's win
together let's be on the same team
together we can both win both separately
and together as a couple i am not your
competition babe stop fighting me and
fight with me and here's another thing
and even when i told you so does anyone
want to call in i want to test the
call-in feature if someone wants to call
in like dm me i'll pick one of you my ex
this on instagram just dot pearly things
he felt like he needs to boost me up to
boost my self-esteem you can like debate
me on something
that wasn't it you need to be bigging me
up whether i'm in your presence or not
what you say about me when i'm not there
is also important too we live in a world
of social media so if you're not posting
my pictures if you're not posting us
together if that's your thing if you're
not promoting what i do on your stories
oh my god she's not
oh man even on your main feed and i want
to just do a
okay i
[Music]
oh gosh
oh gosh i think women and men see
postings so different
and
i have definitely felt some type of way
with my ex-boyfriend because he like
barely ever posted me we'd be together
like all the time i feel like what sir
like why don't you want to show me off
like as women we take that's so personal
but is it like a deal breaker if a guy's
not that into social media
i don't know side note and i am
concerned about adele and her boyfriend
because when adele's album dropped i
went on his page there was nothing not
even a story to
congratulations babe but i'll hold off
my judgment until a later date i
remember that i put on this really big
event lots of people came and part of
the event was sponsored by nhs and a
part of the event you could go and you
could check your blood type and register
to give blood etc etc my ex at the time
posted on his story guys if you want to
come down and check your blood type we
should come to this event and he posted
the flyer mind you guys the flyer had
nothing to do with giving blood it was
completely different not once did he
post the event as in my girl was put on
an event you guys calm down it was if
you want to give blood calm down and i
saw it and i clocked it and i didn't say
anything and i was just like noted okay
cool but then on the day of my event he
came and he wanted to argue with me
because i asked him that morning babe
are you gonna get up and load the van
which we had already agreed to do he got
upset and felt like who were you to talk
to me like that and who are you talking
to the people that are helping you this
event like that the only person that had
a problem with the way that i was
speaking to the people that were helping
me was him guys that is a red mf flag
and i know you guys have got stories
because i've heard stories about
something similar
adele is somewhere with her man laughing
while you're sitting here crying
why are you gonna remind me i think he's
talking about her but why
i'm alone
okay i'm coming to my event to promote
me and to help me and to make me feel
good what the hell are you there for you
guys need to pay attention to the red
flags
how does he react when good things
happen
for you is he enthusiastic is he your
biggest cheerleader is he saying babe
i'm so proud of you you're so amazing i
knew you could do it and not in these
words in his words how he would react if
something exciting happened right is he
guessing you up is he telling everyone
i i i'm curious if she
was as supportive to him
like as she's been asking because
i don't know you get what you are
a lot of the times
but
i mean
i don't know i think a lot of this is
like she's reading too much into it
everyone i'd be really interested to
hear his side of this anyone know who he
is i'll call him mom about it i don't
want to make this video about my ex but
it's really really important to see the
contrast of what i'm talking about and
also those who may be experiencing these
red flags in their relationship as well
you guys can kind of have a gauge a few
of his friends that i knew before i even
knew him
had a problem with me they wasn't before
our relationship of course i found that
out after the relationship ended but
still his friends didn't necessarily
like or were not for me even though they
knew me longer then i knew him but
bigger than that his mom began to have a
problem with me and what i did for a
living and how i presented myself on
social media and one
let's look at her instagram let's pull
it up
why does it always start me with my dms
i do not need those out there
um
okay let's see
what's what's her instagram it's um
okay
oh my god
i said i spell her name wrong is it two
e's let me try oh there we go
they had a problem let's look at her
instagram
it's not too bad what do you guys think
of this picture
what do we think
um
is this it
for real
i don't think this is bad actually but
let me know in the comments
um
let's look at tagged pictures
she have another instagram
i swear i've looked at her instagram
before and it was a lot more like
scandalous i swear i have
like the last time i did this video like
six months ago
interesting what do you guys think of
this ig in the comments i don't actually
think that one was bad
one of the recurring and big arguments
and things i had against him in a
relationship was that i didn't feel like
he defended me i would always question
like what on earth do you tell these
people for them to have such a negative
view of me it seems like you're painting
me out to be some kind of monster and
it's really annoying me because all of
my friends have only positive things to
say about you because i've only ever
bigged you up and made you seem like a
king it just doesn't make any sense how
your people don't ma'am you're
complaining him my people fading on the
internet i don't um and i've done
nothing
oh actually i'm curious you guys think
i wonder if you guys would think my
instagram's bad
i don't think mine is but
you know i'll let you guys i'll let you
guys peep it
i don't i'm open to criticism let's see
real that was a picture of me in high
school look at
cutie
let me see
okay
a little leg
got one that's my brother's girlfriend
she's amazing i'm obsessed with her
oh we got this one
anyways i'm i'm just curious because i
really didn't think hers was too bad but
you guys are putting 304 in the comments
i'm like would i be would i be in that
whatever okay anyways
um
he would swear till he's blue in the
face that he defends me right and so i
had a dream one night and the dream was
there was this african-american high
school oh my god everyone's like girls
peak at 22. no i think i peaked at 19 oh
my god i was so hot when i was 19.
oh my god but i started a meal plan
today you guys get ready your girl's
gonna be hot it's gonna be
it's gonna be
a skinny girl summer i'm not gonna say
hot girl scummer skinny girl summer
towards me shouting yelling arms waving
and she slapped me across the face wait
what hold on
sorry i was half listening let me see
there was this african woman walking
towards me shouting yelling arms waving
and she slapped me across the face and i
turned to my left and my ex was standing
there and he said and did
nothing oh
okay i'm sorry i agree with her i agree
with her there i'm sorry
i'm sorry if you if you had a girlfriend
and you do not
there is nothing more unattractive than
a guy that like does not defend his
girlfriend i'm sorry
but if i get hit by a girl
obviously he can't hit her back
but if he just does nothing oh my god
oh my god i
i'm sorry i agree with that point i do
listen when god speaks to you in dreams
pay attention silly me though i woke up
i've had the weirdest dreams in my life
god does not speak to me through dreams
i had a dream of him he kind of like
laughed it off and was like what you
think i don't defend you i'm not gonna
defend you and i was like i don't know
about that dream really really like
rattled me but he kind of like played it
off like that's not gonna happen but i
really did keep that dream close to my
heart and i really felt like god was
telling me this man is not going to
protect you period but listen guys if a
man cannot protect you emotionally
mentally spiritually physically he's not
ever ever ever how is a guy going to
protect you spiritually
y'all are asking for too much
my mom is more religious than my dad
look at all the church stuff my mom
dragged us to
have you guys heard me say bad things
about my dad no my dad's amazing he's
literally such a good person so
was it his job to protect my mom
spiritually
he'll nuts going to be enough for you
that is his capacity and you either
accept it or you leave it alone so let's
talk about shrinking for a little bit
and i read this post from a girl called
caitlyn i follow her on instagram and
she recently got engaged and when i read
this post it really confirmed that i
needed to make this video she wrote this
post about her husband and i'm not going
to read all of it i will put it on oh no
we're going to compare other
okay so you guys can screenshot it if
you want to read it she said one thing
i'm most grateful to god for is giving
me a man who i didn't have to shrink for
i've had to unlearn and sacrifice but
i've never had that uneasy feeling of
needing to shrink who i am it's that
unsettling feeling of having to slow
down
hide down play or dilute the weight of
who you are
and what you contain
ah shivers i had felt it many times
prior to meeting philip i knew that i
couldn't happily exist let alone grow
with that at the foundation of a
relationship when i met philip i was
stunned by his security he knows who he
is in christ and isn't intimidated by
anyone that is key don't be intimidated
by me but don't be intimidated you guys
think that sounds like a beta
kind of sounds like a beta let me know
in the comments any man either from the
infancy of our relationship he would
show intrigue and support for the call
of god on my life and all of the
complexities that it see it's
it's hard because the woman in me
understands a little bit what she's
talking about okay
like again i i'm driven i have a lot of
hobbies i work really hard at the things
i do
okay i'm very i'm passionate i'm very
passionate about things i wouldn't want
to be in a relationship where i couldn't
like do my youtube channel where i
couldn't
do music and like just do the things
that i'm really passionate about
like i i that would
that would take life out of me to be
honest because like this type of stuff
just like gives me life and
you know i know like the manosphere will
talk about like you have to be willing
to like give up everything for that guy
but that's just not what i would prefer
to do i'm sorry i'm sorry okay i'm sorry
um
but
but it just sounds like she's like
looking for a guy that isn't real
like he has to guide you in everything
but he also like you want him to guide
you in everything but he also can't
make you shrink
if he's the one leading then you have to
shrink a little bit
like
i just sometimes these women describe
these men that like i don't even think
exist like i don't even think they're
real
it involves and as we blossomed as a
couple he constantly made it his joy to
create an environment for me to flourish
from giving me ideas for my law essays
to helping me sort out my itinerary
ministries often times women write
checks they can't cash when it comes to
a fight okay well this lady just came up
to her and hit her like assuming she's
telling the truth right i don't just go
into things assuming everyone's lying
about everything this is crazy [ __ ]
that just came up to her
and he was a dude you're gonna do
nothing oh my gosh that would
i would understand if she was like doing
some crazy [ __ ] but she doesn't really
appear to me to be like super ratchet to
the point she's like starting fights
with people it might have just been a
crazy internet person
when i go over and elsa you shouldn't be
with a girl that's starting fights like
that i'm sorry you should not you should
walk away from that relationship if
she's doing that this man has enriched
my life and will ease to what can be a
demanding journey
okay again i'm blocking people that are
pretending to be people they're not stop
it that's not cool i could cry i could
cry right now god has truly donovan's
not in the chat that's a that's a bot
me with a man who can stand beside me as
an equal in my highest moments of
victory and still handle me with
tenderness in my most fragile moments
that the world would never
see his love was something i had always
hoped for but deep down doubted its
possibility but as always being with
philip reminds me of the truth that what
the scripture says that nothing is
impossible with god i'm glad i didn't
shrink for companionship despite the
many temptations too i'm thankful that i
okay it says 50 of what used to drive
men was the possibility of kids of
legacy
modern women
are not seen as promising prospects so
they don't need to aspire to take care
of anything but themselves
yeah well that's what i'm saying then
don't date them oh my gosh
like
i'm sorry you should want to protect the
girl you're with okay i
i'm i'm not talking about girls that are
like starting fights all the time super
ratchet like that sort of thing you
shouldn't be with those girls
but you should want to protect the girl
that you're with
like that's like saying yeah some girls
are so ratchet they should just be by
themselves duh like what do you
oh my gosh
i didn't abandon the vision called place
when she was talking about the woman
hitting her it was in a dream oh it was
a dream
i must have missed that what is she
oh my god the one the one point where i
was like i could see your point of view
on that you should get a guy that like
wants to protect you
it was a dream
stop oh my god in my heart for a kingdom
marriage and family because of temporary
discontentment i often felt the peace
the liberty the rest this kind of love
was so worth the wait
god when
no that is so beautiful oh my god that
is so beautiful honestly like i feel
like this lady just said like a whole
lot of nothing i swear to god
read it when he first posted it but
reading it again was like
that's what we asked for that's all
we're asking for and it's like she said
that uneasy feeling of trying to put
your foot into a size free shoe when you
wear a size seven it's uncomfortable for
you and it's uncomfortable for the shoe
you almost feel like an obese person
trying to
get with someone that is also guys
consider sending a donation okay as you
guys know all donations right now
i'm putting my heart and soul into this
all donations are going towards
equipment a hundred percent of the money
that you send is going towards eight
mikes so i'd like six or seven people in
here like two guys four girls four or
five girls
i think that's a really good number um i
think past eight it's like a little too
big but in order to host that many
people i need another sound board um
probably another table here
i'd really like to like soundproof this
room like there's just [ __ ] i'm trying
to get and i can't do it unless you guys
get donations because i've already put
like probably a thousand dollars of like
my own money into this and all the money
i've made off of youtube the last like
month and a half two months so it's
really gonna come dependent on like the
donations that you guys send i promise
i'm gonna put on a great a literally a
great show
i'm this is going to be great content
but i can't do it without you so
anyways
appreciate you if you've watched a
couple of my live streams consider
donating because
i know i'm entertaining all right y'all
your girl
is entertaining y'all for free for free
but i'd like to get paid to send money
please
you almost feel like a bomb
hitting a house
right unless almost like you're trying
to shrink oh my god stop pretending to
be other people i'm blocking you stop it
this isn't cool
i mean to be able to comprehend or to
get on their level and it's like i don't
want to get on your level like i need
you to come up stop talking about social
medias not talking about stupid stupid
irrelevant immature stuff stop talking
about stupid stuff i don't care give me
some intellectual stimulation i'm not
saying this because a guy is young he
may not mentally be there a guy could be
five years older than you and still be
younger than you mentally
oh that's true
women mature a lot faster than men
this is what i do think we should push
age again i think a lot of the problems
that women have
like
even when i was dating in college it was
really hard to like
find guys that were like looking for a
relationship and it was because i was
dating guys in my age like what 18 to 21
year old is like dying
like a guy that women want to be with at
18 to 21
like is dying to settle down
not really
um
so
i think like a lot of issues would be
eliminated if like girls did age gap i'm
not saying like 20 years i think that's
a little much but like
even in college like if you're
19 or 20 and like a guy that's 10 years
older than you i think it's fine i
remember a guy that i went on a date
with just one day after i broke up with
my ex and he said to me like how old was
your ex and i told him one or two years
older than me and he was like no you
need a guy that is older neither guy
that is old okay men don't
want to aspire to take care of a wife
and kids because the modern woman
doesn't seem worth the headache it's
easier
for men to just take care of themselves
um
not the headache of a woman
um yeah that's true i'm with you
i'm just saying if you're going to get
in a relationship you should want to
protect her
if someone punches her in the face but i
didn't realize what that situation was i
didn't realize it was a dream
um okay
pearl i like you but i'm calling cap on
that last statement
i i speak very carefully this is what i
said i said
the men that women want like most men at
18 to 21 if they have the option to date
like
like
to not be serious and date multiple
girls like most
will i'm just saying
older danny and i agree with him i agree
that i need someone that is like seven
eight years plus but like most of those
same guys when they hit like 35 40
they're like more looking for something
serious
i'm not saying like there's definitely
guys that like wanted to date
in college right like i'm not i'm not
saying that i'm just saying like
most of the guys that like girls want to
be with
don't don't want that at 18 to 21. same
time i'm not going to be like if god
sends me that secure man who knows who
he is that has his stuff in order that
he happens to be younger than me i'm not
going to dismiss him because he's
younger than me but i do know when i
think about maturity and i think about a
person knowing who they are i know it
takes years to get to that place i don't
have to be like oh maybe i have to
shrink to this person maybe we can work
it out no
no no guys all i know is that my husband
is going to be a unicorn i've always
felt this i've always felt like god
you're going to have to drop him out of
the sky because i know my husband is a
unicorn he's a one in a lifetime and
needle in a haystack and i believe that
many of you guys are going to marry a
unicorn as well that's why they're not i
think a lot of these girls watching this
are going to be single
which is a little ironic because i am
watching it right now
can't win them all so readily available
right you might not meet them on tinder
you might not meet them on a hinge you
might not meet them on social media you
might not meet them at the grocery store
you might not meet them at that event
you might not meet them out in these
streets because they're not out in these
streets right they're getting their
second and third degrees they're
hustling they're keeping their head down
they're starting that business they
aren't sitting on podcasts talking down
on women they're not in youtube comments
slagging women off and taking out
oh their god
young men avoid commitment and young
women avoid accountability so it evens
out
probably
hurt and their pain on women that never
hurt them they're busy building
businesses oh my god that's such a
cop-out i hate that and they're hustling
and quiet and they're becoming husbands
to me
she admits that her imaginary husband is
in fact imagining
ladies don't get discouraged because you
went to this single event you went to
this event you went to this church you
went to that church you did this you did
that and you still haven't managed to
find him don't worry about that
understand as you are preparing yourself
to be a wife he's also preparing himself
to be a husband oh my god how much
preparation do you need i do not think
that much um
i was led
okay let's see what the comments say um
it's not men's responsibility to hold
people accountable just walk away if
it's taxing you sure
i was led to believe most girls aren't
as humble as you
i think i have like self-esteem like
issues so
like i don't think it's a positive thing
i'm gonna be honest like i think it's
actually a character flaw um
we need to double the amount of likes on
this video we do how many likes we got
um
i can't even see hold up
let's see
i want to decorate your studio with a
mural or something
send a donation
the problem okay here's the problem is
this is the this is the only spot i can
put all this stuff in my apartment
um because where i was sitting before
was like a hallway so it's like enough
room for a desk but it's not gonna fit a
table like this
problem with this is this
is a screen and a window
so it's like
i where would i put the mural it'd
probably be over here
anyways i don't have a lot of money
right now i've spent a lot of money on
this [ __ ] so
some money
if you want to
send a picture like if any of you guys
want to paint anything for the pre like
this podcast i will absolutely
put it up for sure
they want a ready-made husband instead
of being able to build with a man that's
true
true
okay what else do you guys want me to
react to i think some people put stuff
in the chat earlier
i might throw some chicken in the oven
really quick though hold on i'll be back
put stuff in the chat for me to react to
hold on hold on
okay
um
so
so
all right guys
back sorry
sorry about that
this is the struggle of being
broke
okay um
let's
see if any of you put anything in the
chat
um
oh my gosh thank you oh my god
guys
oh my god thank you so much
a 30 30 total super chat i'm gonna cry
um
oh my gosh you guys are too much thank
you thank you thank you thank you
oh my gosh um
okay um what what's the video
your first girlfriend what not to do
okay
bye sava okay oh wait hey siri
set an alarm for 20 minutes from now
hopefully i'm just like guessing with
the chicken
um
um okay
what is his name
savo central
this is the girl guy that girl guy
torsha likes right
um
i can't find this video ellie
um
um
it says
rather you know it or not i've been
subscribed since your first red pill
reaction video uh
uh uh-uh ellie we are not we are not
playing with the chords today
oh no child you want to come up you want
to come up
with me come here come here
guys don't get a dog until you're
established that
that is my advice can you guys see her
i'm just curious can you see her in this
okay a little bit
um
okay
let's see
chill chill sit sit chill you can you
can sit with me
but we got it we gotta be chill
um okay i can't find this video
i don't know why
i do not enjoy these thumbnails they're
too
much
um
okay let's see let's see
oh here i can search
um
can you this is going to be one of the
most important videos i've ever made
it's 17 minutes y'all are killing me but
sit tight and take notes this is going
to be a thorough list of things i'd like
young men to consider before getting
into their first relationship before
having their first committed girlfriend
i'm going to be the ultimate big brother
figure on this one and give you guys an
understanding of what you're getting
yourself into and how to properly go
about it these are things i wish i knew
before i had my first girlfriend because
when you do eventually find yourself a
girlfriend as a teenager or a young
adult who pulls you aside and explains
to you the severity of this situation
maybe your parents tell you to use a
condom and get a firm handshake if you
meet the girl's dad but who pulls you
aside and says son you're 17 years old
there's a lot you need to understand
about how developing feelings for a
person is going to affect you and here's
the best way to handle those feelings
who's having that conversation nobody
people are like oh you got yourself a
girlfriend that's cute and just let you
figure it all out on your own when i got
into my first segway dads are supposed
to be there for relationship i didn't
know anything about women as most of us
don't at first but it's just amazing
that your family and parents are like oh
that's great you've got a girlfriend
that's kind of like telling the family
hey i joined a fight club just thought
it'd be a good idea and the family being
like oh that's great he fights now he
doesn't know how to fight but i'm sure
he won't get the [ __ ] beat out of him
this should go just fine granted in most
cases our parents are either divorced or
in dysfunctional relationships
themselves just like our aunts and
uncles and siblings and most of our
friends like if you haven't i have
youtube premiums i don't have to deal
with that notice this is something that
nearly everyone is horrible at now
whether i believe monogamous
relationships are natural or logical is
besides the point because you still have
a better shot at a successful
relationship if you have an
understanding of a few crucial things
that hardly anyone understands
especially not at first love is not a
movie love is not a tv show a novel or a
poem love is a physical and emotional
addiction to a person falling in love is
falling into it yeah your brain is
literally on drugs
like literally on jokes when you fall in
love that's why
i have like every guy i've only fallen
love twice okay i've been in love twice
and every time
i fall in love very hard
like when they talk about like pair
bonding i'm like oh my god i do not have
a problem with that if anything i pair
bond too hard
because i just oh my gosh i fall in love
like very hard obsession and temporary
insanity but hollywood has forever
depicted this state of insanity as a
state of [ __ ] magic so if you've
never had a girlfriend this is what
you're probably imagining having one
might be like you get a girl you're
really nice to her you do a lot of nice
things for her in return she falls for
you the same way you fell for her and
you hold each other until the sun
explodes i live in the world of fantasy
so this is exactly how i approached my
first relationship i'm a writer i'm a
poet i'm a filmmaker i literally took
cues from movies and thought i was going
to live out a [ __ ] romantic comedy
without understanding the true dynamics
of male female relation that's true
that's true
don't put your girl on a pedestal so
here's a few crucial things to
understand and get in check before
entering into a relationship my first
relationship was an absolute [ __ ]
[ __ ] show because i didn't understand
any of these things so take notes or
suffer the same fate as many of us do
our first time around and for some
people every time around being that some
people never learn this information
number one address your trauma sounds
like an odd starting point i understand
but bear with me it's important to
understand what you may be
subconsciously seeking in a partner i
for example had a really shitty
relationship with my mother growing up
she was really nasty to me i hate it
yeah that's true that's very true and so
guess what i went out and found a woman
exactly like my mother same sign same
positive attributes same negative
attributes i was subconsciously seeking
that i do not think i date men that are
like my dad
like
like
there's somewhat there are some traits
that are
but
some not i don't know sort of feminine
love from a woman i felt was missing
from my life due to my poor relationship
with my mother it's no surprise that my
friends who don't have moms cling to
women for dear life in the same way it's
no surprise girls without fathers cling
to a male lover for dear life all our
trauma comes from childhood guys and
this is where it manifests may sound
overdramatic but it's true i also want
to say what cues did you pick up from
your father my father cried in front of
me spazzed in front of me spazzed out on
my mom in front of me i never saw how a
man properly leads his woman earns
respect from his woman maintains his
woman's attraction and so as a result my
first girlfriend made me an emotional
wreck because i had no clue how to deal
with my feelings for her if you're a
lonely guy who also dealt with similar
things oh my god
there is no god ellie
there is nothing you can do to lose like
make a girl lose attraction for you like
then just be more emotional in her oh my
god
oh my god
i just
i i'm not on the camp like don't ever
show your emotions to you girl but like
if you are more emotional than her
you're gonna have issues family issues
trust that a girlfriend is not the
answer to your problems you won't get
the love you always wanted it will bring
to the surface any emotional baggage you
carry so these are things to be aware of
did you watch your dad hit your mom did
you watch your parents fight did you
have an absentee parent did you have
parents who never communicated or never
showed affection towards each other all
these things were subconsciously
absorbed as you were growing up it is
your reference for what a relationship
looks like number two choose wisely if
you are completely inexperienced with
women it is not wise to commit to the
first girl that ever takes interest in
you because you gotta have some level of
experience under your belt to know how
to properly navigate a situation with a
woman going in blind has you act on
emotion and instinct only which is a
great way to do all kinds of things that
turn your woman off weaken her interest
and weaken her level of respect for you
when i say choose wisely i also mean do
not wife the neighborhood ho and then
complain that you don't trust her you
don't like how she
i says you get nervous when she goes out
or when she doesn't get back to you
right away some of you guys are going to
be insecure with all women and that's
besides the point but some women you
don't stand a chance of feeling secure
with even if you're naturally a very
secure guy early on i dated girls who
wore the most revealing clothes and
didn't just aim to get attention from
other men they needed other men to lust
after them they needed other men to get
weak when they looked at her now i don't
believe in telling a girl how to dress
but that doesn't work for me it's simply
not my standards but the error i made
was wife and the girl up before i
decided that's not my oh my god what a
guy's more emotional torch just says
it's like having two [ __ ] in the
house instead of one oh my god
yes
yeah oh my gosh yes the standards
whatever you allow for the jump and
you're asking for a relationship on top
of it you're confirming to her that this
behavior works for me it's okay so later
down the line when you start realizing
there's a lot of hoe antics going on and
you're like i don't really know if i'm
down with the hoe [ __ ] it's like well
you wiped the hoe some guys who are more
straight edged tell me hey my girl
drinks and smokes and i don't drink and
smoke and i don't like her friends the
people she surrounds herself with i
always say you know what your standards
are your standards and you're allowed to
have standards you're allowed to want a
boring school girl the guy
has the video
sounds too low on the video
oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay ellie do you want down
if you want down i'll put you down
okay
let me help you
god sorry pop i tried
ah thank you so much
oh my god thank you
um
don't lick my feet now
guys i'm struggle busting i got practice
at 6.
this is i have like
two practices a day
um let me see if i can turn down my
volume a little bit
see if that makes it better
okay
uh what we're not gonna do is then get
involved by the power box
ellie you are not making this easy for
me you are not i'm trying to mom's
trying to stream okay
pro virgin you're allowed to want a girl
that doesn't drink you're allowed to
want a nun if that's what you want but
if that's what you want go out and find
that don't yeah like the question is
what can you get that's the question
like you're allowed to want what you
want on both sides but the question on
both sides is what can you get
that's question party girl and then try
to turn her into a nun that's not how
this works and it's not effective you
will fail at every attempt which leads
me to number three jealousy is a killer
all these points are interconnected so
pay attention to how it all comes
together jealousy and controlling
possessive behavior is a sure-fire way
to get your ass
oh my god oh my god i
there was
oh my god
it's really tiring being with someone
that is like so controlling over
everything
look it
oh my god i have a lot to say on this
topic but i will not
keep going so how do you prevent it also
consider sending a donation i really
appreciate um jan thank you very much
for the
um
20dk case i don't know what that is but
i really appreciate it um
please consider sending money um it's
all going to be put i literally haven't
even taken any money from youtube the
past like two months i've just put all
of my money that i made into equipment
so all the super chats are going
directly towards equipment someday i
hope to take money from it i'm not gonna
lie to you that day is not today
so you're gonna be paying
for another sound board and four more
mic so i can bring on eight people my
first podcast show is going to be friday
at 8 o'clock gmt which is
5 00 p.m
eastern time i don't know 3 p.m eastern
time and
um
2 p.m central time i don't know what the
time difference is in california i'm
sorry
okay
well you have to be securing yourself as
a man to not feel jealous how do you
feel secure in yourself as a man see
it's a rabbit hole of [ __ ] that needs to
be in check before you hop into a
relationship but a short answer i can
give you is to refer back to the first
two points be sure you're not looking to
cling to a girl to be your mommy figure
like in point one oh my god
yes yes yes yes have your own [ __ ] going
on do not make her your world ellie okay
stop why do you keep trying to go by the
power box that is the one place in this
room i don't need you by
the one one place like that's it you can
go anywhere else in this room
shoes wisely like in point two beyond
that there is no such thing as
preventative maintenance in terms of
making sure your woman won't cheat on
you i believe when you do everything
right as a man your woman won't cheat
because some girls are just horny [ __ ]
sure most women though cheat to seek a
sense of confident dominant masculine
energy that you are not providing and if
you want to get possessive and clingy
and insecure on top of it
i think some girls are just cheaters
i think some girls just need that
attention all the time
set your watch right up until the moment
she does cheat now there's a lot of
self-improvement that needs to be done
to feel like the best version of
yourself as a man so that you don't have
ridiculous insecurities but at the end
of the day if there comes a point where
you feel you can't trust your woman it's
ruining your sense of peace and that's a
bad thing to have ruined you need to
leave her there's nothing else you can
do that might sound extreme but what's
the alternative you're gonna sit a girl
down and explain to her that every time
she leaves the house every time she
picks up her phone and every time she
breathes it makes you afraid she's gonna
oh my god that's a you problem that's
not a her problem and i've had those
conversations guess where it got me
walked all over and cheated on my first
girlfriend actually told me that i'm a
submissive person and she was the
dominant one in the relation
yeah
yeah that's if a girl's gonna cheat with
you i'll cheat on you she's gonna cheat
on you you can't stop it it's the same
thing with a guy
yeah so i didn't even know what that
meant at the time i just knew it didn't
sound good but talk about being brutally
honest and it came from having
conversations like that like babe you
know when you pick up your phone and you
know when you leave and when you don't
get back to me right away and she's like
okay i can see what's going on here this
dude's a [ __ ] i got more on that later
number four variety and effort if you've
gained a woman's interest another great
way to lose it is lack of variety you
can't do the same thing all the time and
you can't express love or affection in
the same way every time either the first
time i bought my girl flowers she was
really excited so i started buying her
flowers every month how excited do you
think she was by the 10th bouquet of
flowers you think she was still ecstatic
no it became routine it became expected
it became predictable and boring when it
comes to how much effort this is
actually pretty good advice this is very
like level-headed advice like this is
not as like crazy as a lot of stuff i
see in the manosphere i think being
thoughtful in respect to how much
variety you provide for her is more
valuable than trying really i think
that's with anybody that's like in the
48 laws of power i forgot like
what
they have some version of that but i
can't remember what it was to impress
her in less creative ways don't go
beyond your means and don't go hard on
the paint don't take her to a super
expensive restaurant you can hardly
afford don't try to be oh my gosh that's
the thing guys it is not about money i i
promise you oh my god i promise you we
all we want men that have like a certain
amount of money like we don't we don't
want a guy that is flat broke
but let's let's say you make
60-ish k or more
we don't really care
maybe maybe i'm just speaking for myself
that you know it's possible actually
there are some girls that care
but
it's more about your frame
and the way you carry yourself and like
how attractive you are like
to be honest
women are really good at
spotting henries
we are we are
it's like inner genetic dma dna some
would say baller just try not to be too
repetitive make subtle and affordable
changes in your routine with this woman
in respect to what you do for fun what
you do in bed where you spend time
together and what you do to relax i've
been a showboater guys i've tried to
move worlds to impress my first
girlfriend the most expensive hotel most
expensive necklace most expensive
restaurant the biggest the baddest the
craziest you name it that's what i was
aiming for i was over the top not
mindful and observant and guess what she
was able to read right through me and
see that i desperately yeah because
you're like putting her value above
yours you're like saying i don't deserve
you i need to like spend all my money oh
my god
you guys you don't have to spend a lot
of money on a girl to keep her
okay
that's not enough 90k and above today i
don't think the numbers
really match what you're saying because
i don't think that many people make 90k
and above tried to do these over the top
things to impress her because i
desperately wanted to keep her plus you
can have a pretty decent standard of
living if you do like most people don't
save so if you're okay let's say you're
a 30 year old guy and you've made 60k
for the past like five years like how
much of that are you putting away
and saving
and how much are you spending because
you don't have to tell a girl how much
you made like i don't understand how
these girls
know how much their man makes
you don't have to tell her
but
i don't know we just want a guy who's
like responsible and like
his money is not confident that is a
non-verbal way of saying i feel i have
no value okay i'm gonna go check on my
chicken i'm sorry i'll be back
oh no that's
know
okay
um
uh
thank you
[Music]
wow
okay
okay
back
sorry guys i'm going to be eating um i'm
going to probably mute my mic a little
bit just so
if you don't want to watch this sorry
you girls on a tight schedule let me
tell you
to impress you so i can make it seem as
if i'm more valuable than i am number
five limit your time twice a week tops
i'll give it to you if you're young i
suppose twice a week that's it if you're
21 and up though you should be too busy
chasing a goal to even have more than
two available days a week to spend with
your girl and why spend more than two
days a week together with her in the
first place i just talked about variety
if you're attached to each other by the
hip five days a week it becomes
impossible to have any variety you run
out of things to do do you really need
to be cuddled up with her watching
television every day no and my first
relationship i worked a lot and the
first few months of us being together we
didn't get to spend excess amount of
time together i envied my friends who
had the time to lay around smoke blunts
watch tv and [ __ ] their girlfriends all
summer that particular summer my job
shut down for a week and i was like wow
this is the first time we'll ever get to
spend an entire week together so we made
full use of that entire week guess what
laying around [ __ ] watching movies
and smoking blunts gets old real quick
limit your time you need space from each
other you need time to miss each other
and you don't need to fall into boring
routine number six learn about sex if
this is the first girl you're having
consistent sex with or maybe even the
first girl you ever slept with she is
more than likely not going to tell you
what she likes and she's probably not
going to tell you is pearl ruining baked
chicken
what ruining that that is rude
rude this is actually really good
to be honest
like this is fire get out
you're doing wrong either so if
satisfying her is important to you do
not try improvising your way through sex
read a [ __ ] book i [ __ ] you not make
fun of me all you want it's better to
read a [ __ ] book about the female
anatomy and the female orgasm than to
improvise your way through sex because
of your stupid male ego like you're just
supposed to know how to please a girl
with hard
i don't have any advice on how to teach
you guys to get good at sex i
yeah listen to the men on that one
because i got none any or zero sex
experience it's not gonna happen set
aside your ego and educate yourself and
my first relationship to keep it
somewhat clean i would give attention to
the wrong areas of her body so to speak
and young girls will just awkwardly let
you do [ __ ] that doesn't make them feel
good i think it was like eight months
later till she had finally had enough
and moved my hand to her pleasure spot
so to speak i don't like talking about
this stuff save yourself some
embarrassment and performance anxiety
you are not an experienced man or a mind
reader cop a couple of books and do not
learn from porn the reason being those
girls scream and moan no matter what's
being done to them that's what they're
paid to do you have no clue if what the
guys are doing to them even makes them
feel good or not it's a scene it's a
performance you don't want to go there
number seven respect your woman must
respect you but you don't demand respect
you earn respect don't let her walk all
over you show her you have a backbone
because she's gonna test you to make
sure you have one something you may not
have yet learned about that's true the
penetration
most girls do not get there from
penetration alone
yeah
okay about women is they will sometimes
start [ __ ] just to see how you'll handle
it will he handle it like a little [ __ ]
or am i in fact dating a real man just
checking that's the mentality but a lot
of it is oh my god
i don't think we do this consciously but
i think we do like like a little bit of
banter you know i mean
and if guys get butt hurt over banter
like it's just not fun
also subconscious it's a woman's
prerogative to check in and make sure
you haven't gone soft men have always
understood this but years ago men went
about it the wrong way beating their
wives etc and obviously some guys still
choose to handle it this way today this
is not what we're talking about you
don't yell you don't scream you never
get physically violent but you hold
frame and you earn the right to hold
firm and not back down from her when
she's being ridiculous by doing all the
right things to begin with you do not
get to conduct yourself like a jackass
do none of the things on this list and
hold firm when she has an issue because
in that respect she has a right to take
issue with you in my first relationship
anytime i upset my girl i would drop to
my knees apologize and beg for her
forgiveness i was too afraid to upset
her she took advantage of that and
walked all over me that always leaves
room for a girl yes yes yes yes yes do
not let a girl walk all over you it does
not make you a nice guy it makes you not
have a backbone that's what it makes you
okay
and manipulate you into thinking she can
do no wrong because you're just
overreacting like always and it's easy
to do that when you do always overreact
major point i want to make on this
sometimes based on things we see in our
upbringing we grow up thinking the
louder and more aggressive you get the
more of a man you are it's actually the
opposite getting aggressive and yelling
and screaming when you're upset is a
feminine trait when you get aggressive
from steroids for example in other words
roid rage it's actually not from the
excess testosterone it's because your
estrogen is spiking and that's a fact
last point do not fight crazy with crazy
should she start freaking out and
screaming you do not want to cower any
more than you want to match her crazy
and start yelling and screaming
facts facts don't don't date crazy women
okay if she's screaming at you all the
time that's not the girl you want to
date
but
yeah there is nothing more on a track
day when a dude starts like getting home
oh my god yeah he's speaking facts right
now
he starts acting like that goodbye yo go
home you're acting like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right now go home come talk to
me when you stop acting crazy kick her
out for the night and if that behavior
goes on and becomes a frequent thing
leave her number eight read between the
lines be observant pay attention to your
actions and how she responds to your
behavior and your actions men and women
communicate differently we are not the
same she is not going to tell you
everything she's thinking you cannot
communicate about everything with your
girlfriend because she's only going to
give you so much she'll want you to pay
attention to her enough to figure out
the rest for yourself read between the
lines don't just ask her how she feels
about something and take her answer like
oh this is how she says she feels so now
i know what's the classic example of
this when your girl's in a pissy mood
and you ask her what's wrong what's she
gonna say nothing i'm fine and in a case
like that she wants you to already know
what she's upset about and in fairness
to the woman she wasn't expecting you to
be a mind reader she was just expecting
you to pay attention to her number nine
do not make her your top priority now
that sounds harsh but your woman should
never be your top priority because
there's too fine of a line between she's
my top priority and she's my hindering
obsession there's just no two
sorry i'm
i'm meeting and i'm meeting this um
that's true i think that's part of the
reason my mom is so attracted my dad
because she never came first
she'll complain about it sometimes but
i'm like mom that's what keeps you
attracted to him
two ways about it your passion your work
your goal then your woman comes after
that it doesn't mean beyond caring it
doesn't mean don't love her but we see
plenty of guys throw away all their
responsibility to tend to a woman and
honestly it's not attractive to her
ambition is attractive to her i bent
over backwards for girls i loved when i
was younger you think they said wow he
really bent over backwards for me no
they were like why is he so weak that he
feels he needs to bend over backwards
for me to seal my love and approval be
there for her but don't drop everything
and everyone to tend to her and don't
ever prioritize her over friends family
and people you're close to i've done
this i've watched friends do this become
obsessed with a girl and become distant
from their friends family
i'm sorry when you get a family
um
my dad's the multi like million dollar
whatever
he really have a lot of friends to be
honest
when you're writing a multi-million
dollar business
and you also
have a wife and a lot of kids like you
probably aren't
going to have a lot of time for that to
be honest
um i'm not doing music reactions on my
lives anymore because they keep getting
demonetized
and all that for a period of time just
to spend more time with their girl this
is the worst thing you could do honestly
this is probably should be number one on
the list your brothers your friends your
family whoever you're close with have
been there for you your whole life they
were there before this girl they'll be
there after this girl if you make any of
the mistakes on this list your girl will
leave you and blow somebody behind your
back you don't need to do anything on
this list to keep your friends your
brothers your family in your life so
don't do this it's really unhealthy and
blatantly disrespectful to the people
you're close with like i know you've
been there for me my whole life but she
gives me sex and affection so i'll speak
to you sometime next year this is beyond
the [ __ ] cesspit of simp behavior
don't do it number 10 don't be afraid as
in do not listen to a video like this or
utilize any of this advice simply
because you're terrified of losing her
heat advice like this to be a more
rational man a more thoughtful and
logical lover and the man she needs
that's my list here's a few takeaways
from the list if you're a slacker who
rather me simplify it if you do nothing
else on this list here's one piece
that'll kind of keep things in check
just keep the possessive feelings inside
don't express possessiveness or insecure
feelings and don't show them don't ever
ask her yes
one time i dated a guy
who would literally get mad at me for
like
being
and i'm not talking about like flirting
with men in public
but
i like would just talk to them and like
like i'm a chit-chatter i talk to
everyone i talk to women matt like the
other day
i took a bus to brighton
struck a 45-minute conversation with the
lady
told me about her book
her job
he's got a daughter that lives in london
that's 24.
and i also struck up a conversation
with these guys
on this other bus and they let me play
cards with them but like he would have
gotten mad at something like that
um
um
what do red pills guys date celibate
women yeah
i think so they might have sex with
someone else but they'll still date you
hold up i mean the last piece of chicken
this is so fire like so fire oh my god
who she's talking to where she is when
you're not with her what she's doing or
where she's been even if you feel like
it keep it inside odds are though if you
don't improve yourself a bit as a man
and take this information fully into
account as in everything i stated on
this list it'll be impossible to keep
those feelings inside and you'll ruin
your first relationship like most of us
did and if you're 17 18 19 entering your
first relationship if you fully adhere
to this advice you have a better chance
than any of your peers at having a more
successful relationship and if your
woman's had previous boyfriends you have
an advantage over all of them because
you watched this i know that's an
egotistical statement but trust i really
took my time on this one if you think
for any reason i might not know what i'm
talking about disregard all this
information and enjoy your relationship
i'm sure nothing will go wrong
it's kind of funny
oh my goodness
that was so good
i'm getting good at cooking chicken i'm
not even gonna lie to you i thought i
burnt it at first i didn't i was like oh
my god because there's so much
smoke that came out of the oven but
oh my god that was so good
sing sim let me look up the bitty person
hold on
i'm gonna put my plate away i'll be
right back hold on
um
is that some cheeky nando's oh my god i
love nando's i eat nando's hot sauce
with like everything
okay
um
this is music
um
s i
mg
oh um
in this cookoff kim chloe and courtney
will
uh this really isn't my type of content
but
i'll try it
and this cookoff kim chloe and courtney
will be making breakfast lunch and
dinner for our three judges each meal
will be scored out of five stars and
whoever has the most stars by the end
wins the cookoff the cookoff starts now
for my dish i want to make something
very complexion so i'm making toast with
a small dab of butter to top it off
first i've gotta make the bread
i'm pretty sure flour goes in it and
maybe like eggs having handmade bread is
what will give me okay this it looks
kind of stupid i'm not gonna lie to you
my mouth is still like watering that's
hot
okay let me hold up let me see if
anyone's dm meme
hey
um
i'm not reacting to music videos
oh my god i'm getting tired
before practice
let me see i think the practice is at
six it's almost five
yeah it's six
where are you getting videos to react
from people either send them in or like
i look at my dms like people will send
them
um
um
hold up
i see something really quick
how long do you think you should wait
after a breakup till you date again i
was like
wondering i think i'm gonna wait um
okay andrew tate actually i should react
to him
um
[Music]
why you should never visit a therapist
okay
oh my gosh okay
if you've been watching my channel for
long enough you know that i have a gripe
with many things and i'm always right
i'm eternally correct if i have a gripe
with something
then that something
is in trouble because my logic
is infallible
and i have hey ellie no
do not she's chewing on something with
therapy as a whole what is therapy well
therapy is the idea that you need to go
through life
crying about the bad things that have
happened to you to some other mortal
being as if they are god
and that somehow that makes things
better you need to go to some other
normal human with their own problems
who's no better than you and sit there
and go oh this happened that happened
and that somehow this inaction is going
to improve your life one of my largest
problems with therapy i don't know
sometimes people feel like they have no
one to talk to
an
antithesis to my and also therapy helps
you because those people are trained and
how to like deal with certain problems
like therapy helped i had a brother that
had like or i have a brother that has
like
like we adopted him so he had like
certain issues um
and the therapy did help him like it
really did like it helped him deal with
like his anger from like bad childhood
world view and my worldview is that
action always wins
momentum speed power forward forward
forward anyone who's done business with
me knows the first thing i say is okay
good idea how quickly is it done the
sooner it's done the sooner it makes
money if it takes two days instead of
one day that's one extra day we've lost
we can never make money during you want
to be a millionaire do things quickly
action wins therapy is not action
therapy is sitting and crying and
complaining talk is not action a [ __ ]
chit chat
is an action
i love the word chit chat
no g knows
action is doing something if you feel
depressed gee you're going to spill
[ __ ] coffee and you're ruining my
tape speech piss off
if you feel depressed
you go to the gym you do something you
don't sit and cry about it and while i
feel depressed let's go sit and have a
talk
words don't count as action not in the
harsh realm yeah but like
i don't know sir therapists give you
tools
therapy is not supposed to be a
long-term thing like they're supposed to
give you things to work on every single
week
to deal with [ __ ] reality so that's one
of the first problems i have with
therapy the second problem i have with
therapy is therapists don't want you to
get better
therapists want little piles of goo they
can poke at little weak individuals they
can just poke at and ask stupid
questions to we're going to pay an
hourly rate forever
it's not in their business model to
improve your life it doesn't make any
sense they just want to sit there and
let you just talk [ __ ] as long as it
takes what's crazy about this is how can
you go and sit in front of a therapist
and not and not cross your mind that
this this therapist has a [ __ ] life
anyway
all these therapists are getting
divorces and cheating on their [ __ ]
lives and are just
well yeah because therapists aren't god
but it's it's ignorant to think that
somebody that's been like listening to
people talk about problems for 20 plus
years doesn't have any experience or
anything that could help you
i i disagree with that is you if
therapists understand psychology so well
why are they all living these perfect
ideal lives well they're not because
they don't know [ __ ] the idea that
they're
okay is somehow necessary or mandatory
is it just i don't think it's necessary
or mandatory but i think it helps people
get through trauma like
there are people
that don't know how to deal with
emotions and they didn't get that from
their parents
so
age western garbage
the thing with all this new age [ __ ] is
that some things should be universal
across the human condition if therapy
was so necessary it would have been
necessary forever the fact that it
wasn't necessary before and is now
necessary means it's new think new age
and you've been conditioned to believe
that you need it people survived without
it for a very very long time
yeah have you ever seen that girl that
came from north korea lived this like
crazy life right
and
she was like therapy like she did not
understand
the concept of therapy because she was
so traumatized and like she'd been
through so much she's like you're going
to therapy because you're heartbroken i
literally was like raped when i was 12.
therapy is not necessary action versus
inaction therapists live in a world of
inaction to sit and chit-chat and talk
and discuss
a lot of therapists are feminists though
well yeah
vet your therapist sure
absolutely vet your therapist when you
that time you had that orange juice uh
like who gives a [ __ ] i live in a world
of action and you know what action is
physical force
action me standing up is real action me
whooping someone's ass is real action
sitting there having a chit chat and
writing things down is in action
therapists live in a world of inaction i
live in a world of action and as i said
in the beginning action always trumps in
action
i know what he's talking about i do
think we live in a society of like over
that's like over therapy-ist
as weird as that is to say right i i do
genuinely think that
but
some people are very very broken
very very broken okay and they need help
and a lot of times they don't get that
from their immediate friends and family
so
it's my test case robin williams is the
case people often come to me and say
well depression isn't real why did robin
williams kill himself
i heard that wasn't exactly true like he
killed himself because he was sick
that's what my dad told me i don't know
i didn't like google it or anything so i
could be wrong but i heard that robin
williams like
killed himself because he was sick
and he was like going to like die from
that sickness
therapy is why robin williams did 12
years of therapy for 12 years not only
was he taking mind-altering
antidepressant drugs which is a video in
and of itself why i'll never do
anti-depressants but on top of that
every single day he's sitting there with
a therapist if you sit in front of me
yeah 12 years is too much
um
i agree with the pills the comment about
the pills been exposed that
pharmaceutical industry along with the
therapist shrinks will throw pills
at people right right true true yo you i
don't understand why more people don't
talk about changing your diet
i
i was on add medicine for like
a year in college maybe like my senior
year college and i went off it because i
was like you know what and same with the
same reason i don't get botox i'm not
above botox i just don't want to look
weird like these girls will look so
weird but
i said i'm going to do everything i can
diet wise before i go on medicine or get
botox or anything like that
because
i don't know
like i just feel like you should do that
before going on drugs um
am i religious
yes and no
rolo i have a video called rolo ruin the
church for me and that's kind of how i
feel
um i am religious i just think religion
has a lot of flaws if i'd identify
something and be like christian or
catholic i'll probably always go to
christian church just because i prefer
it
but i think the catholics make a lot of
points
a lot of points all day every day and
talk about all the bad things that have
ever happened to you all yeah robin
williams had als and didn't want to face
more severe symptoms yeah so it's a
little bit different than just like
being depressed
do you want to like i'm sorry if i if
i'm gonna start to lose my ability to do
[ __ ] take me
take me god i do not want to live
i do not want to live
if i
i'm losing my ability to like
be full of life it's not even about like
how old you are it's about how full of
life you are and if i if i'm like losing
my mental and motor functions take me i
do not want to be a hero
all day every day you're gonna feel
pissed off even i would want to jump off
[ __ ] bridge if i spent 12 years
talking to some [ __ ] about all the
bad things that's happened in my life
it's detrimental sitting there crying
about bad things is never going to help
you if you're the kind of person who
feels like they need therapy you need
someone to talk to to make me feel
better do you know what you are you're
useless because in the harshest
realities of this cold world there are
people in syria whose entire families
have been blown to with a bomb from the
sky who are still getting up every day
making bread and selling on the streets
so they have enough money to buy a new
pair of sandals sometime next year well
you're crying about nothing with your
first world [ __ ] to some therapist
who probably does coke on the weekends
my final point on therapy
is as follows it is detrimental not only
is it useless not only is it not science
not only is it [ __ ] it actually
makes people worse the worst thing you
can do if you have a problem is sit and
talk about it all day
people say you shouldn't bury your
problems because if you repress them
that's [ __ ]
world war ii how many people died did
everyone sit around and [ __ ] go oh we
don't have time to rebuild all the
cities and
create the nhs oh my god
he's right though that is a first world
problems i've had friends that their
wives leave them for stupid reasons and
they had to fire multiple therapists
because the way they approached
treatment
accurate yeah
that's true look at
i would guess that there are more
therapists than there are like bad
therapists and good ones if i'd guess
but i'm just saying i i saw how therapy
worked on my brother and
it helped him he was traumatized and it
they gave you tools to deal with certain
emotions that a lot of people don't
learn growing up
we need to sit and talk about all the
bad things happened every single person
has a horror story from russia to
germany through france england america
the japanese the philippines everyone
has something bad to say so let's
somehow clone the entire population of
earth so we have enough therapists and
sit there and talk all day instead of
getting [ __ ] done [ __ ] up and they
got [ __ ] done there's nothing wrong with
[ __ ] having something bad happen to
you internalizing it the best you can
maybe speaking about it with someone
close to you but in general just shut
the [ __ ] up and get along with it there
are people i do think
friends are better to talk to
and that's why i'm always really
grateful to have like my family because
they help me a lot like my brother
even like this last breakup i just went
through
um
like i again i get attached very easily
and i get like like i fell in love very
fast and like hard
and when it doesn't work out i get very
sad um and it's very hard for me to be
honest like
i don't know when they talk about like
girls will like move on like that
um that's never been me
um i would like it to be that sounds
really nice
but it's been nice because my little
brother adam has been like so nice with
everything he's like whenever if you
want to like reach out to him or like
you miss him whatever just like call me
and we'll talk
and
it's not like i call him every day you
think you would kill me but you guys get
the idea like it's nice to have someone
that kind of like has your back for when
you're like going through [ __ ]
um
okay i think doug
um
had something
i forgot what he sent
oh no my phone just died
my phone is where i read the comments
but luckily i have two phones
um because one's my us phone but it
works on wi-fi and one's my american
phone
or my british phone
people always think it's sketchy um
which is fair
um okay let's see
oh i had that vulnerability um before
when i was younger the same as you to
getting attached to people with
relationships yeah i don't know man i
just i fall in love fast i do like i
i don't enjoy it about myself because to
be honest like i've stayed in situations
that like i clearly shouldn't be in
longer
and like wasted time
but i don't know i just when i like
really care about someone it's like
really hard for me to leave like very
hard
um
and i think a part of me like always
still like
again i've only been left twice this has
only happened twice but like a part of
me still like will always care for like
the people that i was in love with i
don't know i it's
i wish it wasn't it'll probably go away
at some point like if it fades over time
but
like
i don't know man i
wish i was in that way but i
am
it comes with being like bubbly and like
full of life it's like when we're in
like people that are bubbly and like
full of life when we're in relationships
like we put a lot of ourselves into it
you know i don't know
um
i should put together a rotation of sims
to keep me in a good mood
no i'd rather talk to my brothers um but
oh my god i wouldn't even have time to
put together like y'all didn't even
right now this is what i'm doing
in life i'm trying to start this podcast
i'm playing semi-pro volleyball i'm
getting a psychology degree
i'm trying to see europe while i'm here
right so i'm trying to like go on small
trips i'm also trying to learn guitar
and like start get my first gig
which i've kind of have set up um
i have like a bar that's willing to take
me but i need to put in like the time to
practice and and i'm also trying to get
recruited to play pro next year
you see it's a lot i'm stressed out
oh my god i'm stressed out
and i'm also trying to like focus on my
eating like i just did i'm doing a meal
plan now
yeah
so it's just oh my god it's been a lot
i'm not trying to like [ __ ] and
complain i'm very lucky i'm so happy to
be doing what i'm doing but like your
girl gets like tired as hell
like i feel like i haven't slept in like
a month and and i'm also like going
through like you know i like just got
out of a relationship so
anyways
um
yeah that's that's my life right now
okay why in cells shouldn't be using
dating apps let's go
seems like you're spreading yourself a
little thin i know i am i have to make
decisions actually because
this season
is going to end soon so i kind of have
to make a choice about like what i want
for like next year
because i can stay in the london
or i could go pro or
i could play for this club next year
um
which would be like a less of a time
because right now the problem with this
time commitment is i'm playing for the
school and the club which is normal but
we have like
like the reason i'm dressed like this is
because i come from practice so it's
like like in the middle of the day i
have a one-hour practice and then i have
to come back
and then i have like three or four hours
and then i have
so then i like stream and then i have
another practice or i'll have like a
guitar lesson in between
so
i don't know i'm just like
i'm just like trying to do my best but i
realized like right now i'm doing too
many things and it's very like
oh my god i'm just tired so i don't have
time to even like get a rotation of sims
but if you know any in the london area
that could help me with things um that
would be nice
anyways i'm going to react to this video
now
okay so we're back with advice on how to
move past your incel stage if this is
where you are in your life i was in this
boat for many years there is a way to
move past this stage of your life
believe it or not become more
comfortable socializing if you have
social anxiety become more confident as
a man learn social skills eventually
become comfortable talking to women and
then learning the proper techniques to
be able to attract and eventually you
would hope to be able to maintain a or
multiple women's interests but man is
there a long road ahead of daily
self-improvement steps that need to be
taken to make it through each of these
stages and while most people look for an
easy fix to rather dramatic issues
there is no easy fix to improve all
these issues and move on to a stage in
your life where you are no longer an
insult we're not just talking about that
degree oh my gosh hold on i want to oh
my god i hate this degree but i have to
do it to keep my visa if i don't if i
could quit the degree i would but in
order to stay here i have to get it
that's the only reason i'm getting it
oh my god i get so mad whenever i have
to do [ __ ] for my degree because i don't
want to
hearing a few crucial pieces of advice
we're talking about a complete overhaul
change of your life and so understand
part of what i'm here to do is offer
advice in respect to the
self-improvement measures that need to
be taken to move past your incel stage
but in order to get you to understand
how crucial it is that you take these
steps necessary being that it is the
only way to improve i need to dismantle
all the shortcuts and being that i run a
gaming channel and a lot of hardcore
internet gamers are the guys that need
to hear this the most i'd say yeah
there aren't shortcuts especially with
like approaching women like you have to
put in the work to get good at it you
have to
some guys
are just like hot and can do it like
that but
no
pearl needs a man to guide her oh my god
yeah i'm so disorganized
yes
say i'm talking to the perfect group
because a lot of you have become masters
at disconnecting from the outside world
due to social anxiety and other related
issues but obviously nobody is 100
anti-social right a lot of you have
friends but these friends are relegated
to the internet to internet pen pals
basically
via social media skype discord or
youtube whatever your choice is so a lot
of guys despite their inexperience with
women and their social media you don't
know how people can play call of duty
for hours yeah like guys if you are into
video games that's so unattractive to
girls i'm sorry
we don't
it's not attractive i'm not saying like
don't ever play video games but
it will not turn us on in the slightest
like it's actually so unattractive to
watch you guys just play video games for
hours id are still trying to find
themselves girlfriends and still trying
to get themselves laid but they're doing
it through the internet and they're
meeting people through the internet
which seems like so can we get to 40
likes please perform 40
safe place for you if this is where
you're at so here's another shortcut
that comes about dating apps bumble
tinder hinge you name it here's why i
don't recommend dating apps for incels
guys i have hinge
but i never meet the guys because i'm
too busy should i delete it
i do have hinge i do have hinge it's
like a fun little
wait it's actually on that phone
but i actually agree
with that because
it's almost like you get that male
attention so i just like don't
go out i don't know
i can't hear the video
if i turn it up then my whole
neighborhood can hear you
i don't know how to turn up the video
um let me see
because it's all the way up on
on the desktop oh the desktop audio
okay let me see now
number one this does nothing to improve
your social skills and on top of it it's
going to hurt yourself does that help
did that help at all
steam even worse if you already why do
people always think i'm gay i get that
so much i literally i don't know it's
because i play basketball i'm just kind
of a tomboy or my voice but i
i don't know why i get this
bad self-esteem to begin with being that
bumble and tinder is a handsome man's
game it's look based and everything
isn't look based with women in real life
you could be a five in a woman's eyes
and talk your way up to being a seven or
eight that's true
that is true
in her eyes with your personality if you
gain her interest sustain your interest
if you're fun interesting to be around
and then it is
focus on one or two things no i know i'm
i really
um like the podcast is the first
thing that i'm like focused on but
again i have to get the degree to keep
my visa
and i love volleyball i'm gonna be
really sad if i don't have to give that
up but i think i have to soon
but maybe one more year i don't know um
isn't 100 about looks but when you're
swiping also yeah consider sending a
donation there's 26 people in here
um again i'm trying to get
eight microphones for this podcast right
now i have four um
i really would like to get eight so i
need
i'm at close to like three hundred
dollars of donations and i need 700 more
to get all of that equipment
um
so consider sending a donation i would
appreciate it profile pictures you're
people shopping for the best looking
thing you can find and you may very well
swipe through 600 women without getting
a single match and then you're already
low self-esteem having asses sitting
there thinking 600 women just passed up
on me
not one out of 600 women is attracted to
me when maybe some of those girls very
well we're relatively attracted to you
but they're people shopping well and
like
okay when you're a girl and you like
this is how i explain it let's say you
have a hundred matches like
i
like
my phone's dead otherwise i would i
would show you
i probably have 50 matches right now
right
and out of this 50 initially what do you
have to go off of just look so of course
you're going to pick the ones that
you're the most attracted to
but like a guy if he's like funny or
holds a good conversation on a dating
app my interest for him goes up
but you're also like kind of at a
disadvantage with me because i'm so
goddamn busy that it's like
oh my god i've like barely i don't even
coming just coming out of a relationship
like with dating apps there's a lot of
[ __ ] that you don't like girls don't
take it as seriously as guys so we'll
just like have it and like you never
know so you keep it on but
i don't know and the amount of options
nearly any woman has both in real life
and through apps especially through apps
and the internet is ridiculous they have
five six hundred seven hundred thousand
men to pick between themselves
they're looking for the best looking cat
ah thank you so much for the five dollar
donation i appreciate you
thank you thank you thank you ah yay
okay because now we're at about like 305
ish i'm you know i kind of lost track
but
we're getting there we are getting there
so consider also sending a donation guys
um again i'm going to work so damn hard
on this podcast i swear to god this is
going to be a great show this is going
to be a great show i'm going to have all
different types of girls on here i'm
going to have japanese girls british
girls
girls from nigeria
men um tall men short men
you know
50 matches it's over lads
no not even because i barely talk to
people on those apps that's the problem
it's like i'm so busy and you have to
understand from a woman's point of view
we're trying to figure out if you're
weird or not we're like why is he on the
app now i know this seems like
but you're on the app right
i know i know but it's really tough when
you don't have any mutual friends
because someone could pretend to be
anyone anyone
anyone so
i don't know
that's that's where i'm at with that not
be unrealistic about the kind of options
nearly any relatively decent and plus
like are the guys in those apps really
marriage minded or they're really trying
to
that's where i get like
torn because i'm like do i really want
to be married right now
no i'm just getting out of another
relationship
i think i need a couple more months and
so then i'm like why do i have these
apps i don't know i get looking girl has
i mean men are dogs dude you gotta
understand that both between getting hit
up on the street at school at work and
having social media any halfway decent
looking woman i honestly want to say has
at least 50 options at a time if not
hundreds so basically imagine from a
woman's perspective do i have 50 options
at a time on an app sure but like
trying to think like right now how many
options that i'm actually interested in
it's not that high of like guys that
we're actually interested in
it's like i
but then again i don't
i'm at home a lot imagine if you had 50
women to choose from at all times who
would be your number one pick which girl
would you take out well probably nearly
all of them but who would be your first
pick
the absolute hottest looking woman of
the group and there could be many hot
looking women in the line but since you
have your choice of all 50 yeah that's
that's what i'm saying with dating apps
but
if you have like a funny bio or you're
like witty i'm telling you you can
like
looks is literally just the first thing
i see and then after that it goes to
like is he funny is how is he able to
hold the conversation
pearl probably has hundreds of guys
trying to date her not really dude um
sorry to kind of stop i'm trying to stop
saying dude but i really like the word
um
you know what maybe like hundreds of
guys that i'm not
like probably would but like actively
trying it's it's not as high as you
think
so even if you are a good-looking guy
the experience from both sides of a
dating app are not mutual for guys women
even read bios if we like your picture
like we're not going to read it
if we do we have to at least like your
picture but if you go get professional
pictures taken like you're going to be
above so many guys because most guys
look better in real life than they do on
abs you are throwing your name in a hat
like signing up for a prize giveaway and
hoping you get picked and sometimes you
do sometimes you don't but most of the
time you won't and as in cells when
we're in this stage of our life we have
the worst self-defeating mentality we
don't take any of these factors into
account and we become even more
self-defeating see i knew i was ugly
nearly a thousand women swiped left on
me not one of a thousand women was
attracted to me i set my range on 300
miles and swiped on every single girl on
the [ __ ] app and nobody wants me see
i knew i was a [ __ ] bum forgetting
you didn't approach any of these women
talk to them or let them get a glimpse
of who you are or why you might be fun
to date and you don't know what's going
on in their lives like again
there's guys i barely respond to on
dating apps it's nothing to do with them
i'm just drowning in things to do at
this point in my life drowning it's
gonna be a better i think hopefully
right now i'm drowning in life
it's not their fault but it's like do i
feel like deleting the app all together
not really like what's the harm of just
having it
you've got a profile and a list of
profiles for a woman to sit back and try
to make out all right who's the
handsomest
who looks the most interesting
who looks like they have the most
interesting life based on pictures so
you see my point you've done nothing to
improve your social skills because you
didn't actually socialize with anyone
you did nothing to improve your
self-esteem because you didn't actually
put effort into anything which is how
you develop healthy self-esteem which is
required to build social skills and in
fact you brought your self-esteem down a
notch lower in the process number two
this has done nothing to decrease your
fear of talking to women let's say you
upload the best looking pictures of
yourself you can take you pretend like
you got it going on and fake like you
have experience with women and a girl
swipes right on you and starts a
conversation now the goal would be to go
out and meet this girl how nervous are
you are you shaking in your boots
probably and the clock's ticking before
the next best thing swipes on her and
she's off on another tinder date are you
prepared to go out and meet this woman
or are you terrified that it's going to
be awkward and you're not going to know
what's going on let's hear shakespeare i
wish my phone didn't
die otherwise i'd show you guys like
messages that piqued my interest
ask about her like sometimes i'll be
really interested in a guy and i'll be
like wait did it do i know anything
about him that's probably my best advice
get the girl talking to say or how to
act you're probably terrified i know i
was back when i used to get myself in
those situations before i had experience
with women or i had experience
socializing girls would take interest in
me and i'd be like cool i've got their
interest they're attracted
but i don't know how to [ __ ] act i
don't know what to say
i was [ __ ] scared shitless so where
has this gotten you if this is where
you're at look i'm a social dude now and
i'm not scared of women but i still
don't feel 100 about going out and
meeting strangers that in and of itself
is already a little uncomfortable you
throw social anxiety and a lack of
experience with women on top of it
you're doomed so what's the point of
swiping in the first place i think this
brings us around to the question what is
an involuntary celibate really looking
for more likely than not an insult is
not just out here looking for the
baddest [ __ ] he can find because that's
intimidating but do you think
it has to be an insult like defined
like how many months without sleeping
with someone in cell's more so looking
for the most halfway decent looking
woman he can find like let's say if a
model status chick is a 10 he's looking
for a five right on the border between
being kind of cute and kind of ugly
because they're not as intimidated and
you figure since she's not as
astoundingly gorgeous as a model maybe
she doesn't have as many options either
wrong again we've all tried to play that
game
[Music]
a million other insecure men had the
same idea i won't go for the hottest
chick because she intimidates me i'll go
for the five or the six but like i said
i don't know if it's always been this
way or it's just because of the social
media age but today oh my gosh i've
heard that the hottest girls like don't
get approached the most because men are
intimidated there's no middle class of
women between ugly and hot if you're a
halfway decent looking woman you have as
many options as a model has and some
decent options also options for sex
though not relationships in my opinion
straight up ugly women that get taken
out on two to three dates a week sorry
to not be pc about that but by the way
girls that find you ugly are not putting
it in the nicest terms when they talk to
their friends either trust me it's just
the way it is what it seems an incel is
really looking for when he searches for
a woman is a a woman who does not
intimidate him be a woman that
understands him and maybe see a woman
with similar interests because it gives
you something to talk about if all you
can really talk about is video games and
comics and anime the main thing it seems
as an in-cell is looking for a woman he
can be himself with in other words i am
broken i am [ __ ] up i don't leave the
house i rarely come out from behind the
computer all my friends are on youtube
and discord i have no social skills and
a plethora of other problems i don't
know how to improve and am even scared
to try
will you accept me anyway now you can go
to the deepest corners of the internet
to try to find this woman on a message
board with fantasies of moving out to
the other side of the country where she
lives so you can have a partner a woman
who does not scare you who you feel you
can be yourself with and from what i
understand some guys have been able to
do it and are happy and good for them
but this should not be the in-cell dream
mainly because it's not fixing any of
your problems and say you should find
that woman and you lose her will you
ever attempt to improve yourself so you
can meet a girl who lives maybe four
blocks away instead of searching the
internet for a soul mate or will you go
back to the internet crying out for help
guys as always the internet is not your
escape go a dating app is not your
escape goat there's no easy way to cut
corners in a situation like this it's
true he's got good advice i'm good on
that one though
okay guys your girl is tired i'm gonna
take like a quick nap before practice
um
okay as usual don't forget to subscribe
send oh my god
oh my god send donations
please
pour for send some donations help a girl
out
the
show is going to be friday at 8 pm
british time so it's gmt
3 pm
eastern time